[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا وحلقه جديده من هو مصر
لنخصصها لمرور عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتاثيراتها على مصر في هذه الحلقه كيف
تاثر قطاع السياحه في مصر خاصه وان مواطني
البلدين يخرج من نصف السياح قبل اندلاع
الازمه واقتصاديا كيف تاثر الاقتصاد
المصري الذي يعتمد في والدته من القمح
والحبوب على البلدين
[موسيقى]
وسياسيا كيف تفاعلت مصر مع الازمه ما بين
روسيا واوكرانيا خاصه في ظل علاقات مميزه
مع روسيا
[موسيقى]
نحن
كدول
اقتصادها
مش قوي
عن الكثير جدا من تبعات
ازمه كورونا سنتين
وتحملناها والان نعاني ايضا من هذه الحرب
انا مش بتكلم فقط عشان احنا بنعاني منها
هنا في بلاد زي بلادنا ولكن انا بتكلم هنا
عشان العالم كله اتصور انه بيعاني من هذه
الحرب انا بقول تاني احنا مستعدين انا
بنادي باسمكم وباسمي ان سمحتولي بكده ان
سمحتولي بكده ان احنا فلتتوقف هذه الحرب
هذا نداء من مؤتمرنا هنا ان سمحتولي بكده
فلتوقف هذه الحرب وهذا الخراب وهذا الدمار
وهذا القتل بالمناسبه احنا مستعدين
[تصفيق]
بالمناسبه انا مستعد ومش
مش للبحث عن دور لا والله ولكن من اجل
العمل
لانهاء هذه الحرب
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اولى فقراتنا في هذه
الحلقه نتناول فيها الموقف المصري من
الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه شريف ان يكون
معنا دكتور مختار غباشي نائب رئيس المركز
العربي للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
اهلا بحضرتك اهلا وسهلا بك تحياتي لك
ويشرفنا كذلك الاستاذ نبيل نجم الدين كاتب
المتخصص في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك يا
استاذ تامر واهلا بالساده المشاهدين
بعد ان استمعنا لهذه الكلمه للرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي وهي كلمه القاها في
افتتاح قمه المناخه التي اقيمت في شرم
الشيخ في نوفمبر الماضي قال انه مستعد
لبذل اي جهد وحتى الوساطه ما بين الطرفين
السؤال هل مصر طرف محايد يمكنها الوساطه
ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا
اذا اخذنا المنطقه العربيه بشكل عام
المفترض انها محايده لان هذا الصراع هو
صراع شرق وغرب
قالوا لفاروف في بدايه هذا الصراع غرض هذا
النزاع انهاء هيمنه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كقبب وحيد على مستوى العالم من
خلال هذه المقوله يبقى بقيه دول العالم
مفترض مفترض خصوصا مناطق النفوس انها
محايده لا مصلحه العالم العربي ان يذهب في
اتجاه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لانه ده
هيشكل عليه ضغط الى حد كبير جدا بحكم
خصوصيه علاقات روسيه ببعض الدول العربيه
على راس هذه الدول سوريا والجزائر ولا
مصلحه العالم العربي ان يذهب ناحيه الروس
بحكم الوصايه الولايه الامريكيه على المال
الخليجي وحجم القواعد العسكريه المنتشره
في العالم العربي فالعالم العربي ما بين
شقي راحه ومن ضمن العالم العربي بالتاكيد
مصر
متصور انه العالم واخد موقف حيادي وهذا
الموقف الحيادي واخده مصر وحجم النداء
اللي اطلقوا الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي في
كوب 27 هو نداء بوقف هذه الحرب واستعداده
انه يقوم باي جهد اذا اوكل اليه يعني اي
شيء مرتبط بهذا الامر معلوماتي انه مصر
كان موكولا اليها اجتماعا في نوفمبر 2022
خاص باتفاقيه الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه اللي
سحبها بوتين في خطابه بعد زياره بايدن
الشهيره الى اوكرانيا والى بولندا مصر على
الحياد العالم العربي على الحياد ظاهريا
على الاقل كثير جدا من دول العالم ليست
لها مصلحه في التورط في هذا الصراع لان
هذا الصراع عنوانه عنوانه اوكرانيا لكن هو
صراع ما بين قوه دوليه وما بين قوى صاعده
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في اخطر
مراحلها وهي مرحله الترهل الامبراطوري
استاذ نبيل مصر في اثناء التصويت كان هناك
ضغوط غربيه عليها قبل ان تصوت على ادانه
التدخل العسكري الروسي في اوكرانيا وتحفظت
على
العقوبات الاقتصاديه التي فرضت على روسيا
وقتها وقيل ان كان هناك ضغوط واضحه على
مصر بشكل على مصر وايضا على الامارات ومن
ثم تصفيتهم جاء في صالح
ادانه التدخل الروسي في اوكرانيا هل
نستطيع ان نقول انها ما زالت عن حيدر
هو في الحقيقه لازم يعني نضع فرق وخط واضح
بين حاجه اسمها الشرعيه الدوليه والقانون
الدولي
والسياسه الخارجيه للدول
الاجتياح العسكري لاي دوله لدوله جاره هذا
انتهاك
لسيادتها وهذا يتعارض مع
القانون الدولي
وايا كانت اسباب الاكتياح
القانون الدولي والشرعيه الدوليه لا تسمح
على الورق على الاقل
باجتياح دوله لدوله جاره لتصفيه امور
معلقه واحنا لو سكتنا
انا بتكلم متخصص في العلاقات الدوليه على
عدم وصف ما جرى من روسيا الفيدراليه نحو
دوله مستقله زاد سياده اسمها اوكرانيا اذا
لماذا نعترض على اجتياح اسرائيل لاراضي
اربع دول عربيه وهكذا في الحقيقه ما جرى
في مثل هذا اليوم 24
فبراير من العام الماضي لان احنا هنتكلم
بعد مرور 12 شهر هو عدوان
مكتمل الاركان من دوله اسمها روسيا
الفيدراليه على دوله اسمها اوكرانيا قد
يكون للرئيس بلدي ميربوتين اسبابه واسبابه
القويه ولكن
مشاكله لا تحل بهذا الشكل لاننا الموقف
الدولي ولكن او على قانون الدولي اذا كنا
نتحدث عن مصر لماذا اصدرت عدد من الدول
الغربيه بيان تطالب فيها مصر
والامارات وقتها بادانه هذا العدوان ومن
بعدها كان هناك ما اعتبره البعض انه
مكافاه لمصر على هذا التصويت لا يجب ان
تعطى مكافاه لوقوفك في الاشاره الحمراء في
الطريق اذا كانت الرد لايت وقفت في الريد
لايت ما تاخذش مكافاه ده الطبيعي
انا اعتقد الامور ابسط في التفسير واعقد
في الواقع ما جرى من موسكو نحوك هو تكرار
لحدث
شاهدناه من قبل
عدوان الامريكي على فيتنام
والمجازر التي ارتكبت في بحق الشعب
الفيتنام ثم
الاجتياح الاتحاد السوفيتي المنحل
لافغانستان
ما جرى في اوكرانيا هو النموذج الثالث نعم
وسينتهي بالمناسبه كما انتهت الفكره
دكتور غباشي هناك من يقول ان مصر مع روسيا
ولكنها ضد الحرب الى اي مدى يمكن تصديق
هذه المقوله مصر مع روسيا وهي ضد الحرب
تفسير مش قادره اوضحه لكن مصر الى حد كبير
جدا بحكم علاقتها بالطرف الروسي عسكريا
واقتصاديا وبحكم اعتمادها على 42% من
احتياجاتها من الغذاء او القمح على الطرف
الروسي والطرف الاوكراني وبحكم ان 31% من
حجم السياحه الشاطئيه بياتي من روسيا
واوكرانيا فهي ضد الحرب بشكل عام لكن من
وجهه نظري ان القضيه هنا مش قضيه انك انت
ضد الحرب او مع الحرب
قضيتك انه ولا قضيه شرعيه دوليه بالمناسبه
يعني دعني ان انا يعني اختلف شويه مع نبيل
به في هذا الموضوع لانه الشرعيه الدوليه
لا يتحدث بها سوى العالم الثالث
احنا بس بنكلم الشرعيه الدوليه احنا اللي
اتكلمنا على 845 قرار من الامم المتحده
صادر لمصلحه قضيه الفلسطينيه واحنا
اتكلمنا على 97 قرار من مجلس الامن صدر
لمصلحتها واحنا اللي تكلمنا عن 96 قرار
صدر مجلس حقوق الانسان وما فيش ولا حاجه
مشيت والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لما
دخلت العراق عسكريا دخلت العراق عشان
برنامج نووي ولما اعترضت المانيا وفرنسا
قالت احنا هنروح نحتلها والخبر راسكو في
الحيطه فيعني قواعد القانون الدولي فيما
هو مرتبط بقواعد الشرعيه مساله كبيره جدا
نستطيع ان احنا الموقف المصري انا اتصور
ان الموقف المصري بجانب الموقف العربي
بصرف النظر عن التصويت بنعم او لا لان هذا
التصويت بشكل او باخر مقصرش على منظومه
التدخل العسكري ان احنا كلنا عارفين ان
التدخل العسكري بالنسبه للروس محصوم
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدرك ده من
2008 وجربت محروس 2014 وكان من نتيجه
جزيره الكرم ولو همسك ودينداستيك وحديث
الرئيس الروسي بوتين مع الرئيس الامريكي
الاسبك بوش 2008 اثناء اجتماعات حلف
الناتو انه ما تقربوش ناحيه اوكرانيا
وملكوش علاقه بجورجيا وما لكوش علاقه
بلاروسيا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
رايحه تحتك في هناك زي ما سخنت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فنلندا والسويد
بالانضمام الى حلف الناتو واضطرت الروس ان
يوجهوا 12 فرقه عسكريه ناحيه الغرب والى
حد كبير جدا كان حديث الروس احنا ما فيش
حاجه بيننا وبين فنلندا والسويد لكن لو
وصلت اسلحه استراتيجيه هجوميه من قبل حلف
الناتو قد لا تحرك عسكريا ضد فنلندا
والسويد فالموقف الدولي بقراءه هذه الحرب
مش مرتبطه باجتياح رسل اوكرانيا اكثر من
هو صراع ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وما بين الروس باعتبار ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تجابه
القطب الوحيد على مستوى العالم ولم تدرك
انها انتهت عند هذه المرحله الفكره واضحه
اخرى مختار افترض ان تصحى استاذ نبيل هل
مصر هي طرف يمكن ان يقوم بالوساطه ام انه
مؤيد لروسيا كما يقول بعض كان هناك مؤخرا
رساله نقلت عن طريق وزير الخارجيه المصري
سامح شكري الى الجانب الروسي اثناء زيارته
كانت رساله من بلينكن كيف نفهم هذا هذا
التفاعل يعني اتحفظ على كلمه ان مصر طرف
مؤيد لروسيا لا ده مش صحيح
مصر معروفه على مدى تاريخها
انها دوله لا تتدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للدول الاخرى يعني السياسه
الخارجيه المصريه بتقف عند نقطه معينه
انما لا يمكن انك مصر تؤيد ما جرى
من موسكو لاوكرانيا
الدكتور تفضل بشيء مهم قال لي ان الشرعيه
الدوليه احنا في العالم الثالث
نقطاته مفهوم او لفظ الشرعيه الدوليه لا
الحقيقه احنا لازم نفرق ما بين حاجتنا انا
لا اريد الدخول في هذه النقطه انا اريد
الحديث عن الموقف المصري هل مصر في مازق
بسبب علاقتها المتميزه بروسيا وفي نفس
الوقت ارتباطاتها مع الدول الغربيه مصر
مؤهله تماما انها تقوم بدور الوساطه بشرط
قبول اطراف الصراع الكبار بهذه الوساطه
موسكو
واشنطن والنيتو في حاله شد الحبل
وبالمناسبه
اذا احب ان انا اوصف لك الوضع او المشهد
الان كل الاطراف اصابعها في الشق
المانيا ويعني حديث وعلاقته عسكريه
وعلاقات متينه مصر توازن ما بين علاقاتها
على نطاق الدوله ونطاق الاقليمي بشكل من
اشكال المناوره بين كل هذه الاطراف لكن
اشكاليتك في هذا الصراع بالنسبه لده انت
بتتحدث عن صراع ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وما بين الروس اشكرك اشكرك
دكتور مختار غباشي نائب رئيس المركز
العربي للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
استاذ نبيل نجم الدين الكاتب الصحفي
المتخصص في العلاقات الدوليه اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا مشاهدينا الكرام نتابع تقرير الزميل
احمد الصفطي حول الازمه التي تعانيها مصر
في القمح والحبوب التي تعتمد بشكل اساسي
على استيرادها من روسيا واوكرانيا
تداعيات الحرب في اوكرانيا لا زالت تلقي
بظلالها على مصر التي تراجع مؤشر الغذاء
فيها وفقا لاحصاءات عالميه الى نحو 40%
مصر هي اكبر مستورد للقمح في العالم تشتري
اكثر من 60% من احتياجاتها من الخارج لذا
تسارع الحكومه للاستيراد من اماكن اخرى
بعد تراجع شحنات من اوكرانيا بسبب الحرب
والعقوبات على روسيا اصبح لدينا ما يقرب
من 22 منشا لاستيراد الاقماح تم اعتمادهم
من الجهات المعنيه فبالتالي ليس هناك اي
تخوف من اي نوع فيما يتعلق بسلاسل الامداد
الخاصه بالسلع الاستراتيجيه وزاره زراعه
المصريه التي اسند اليها ايجاد سبل لزراعه
القمح محليا تقول انها مشكله امن قومي
تستوجب تقليل دوره زمنيه لزراعه القمح
والمحاصيل الاستراتيجيه بسبب الحرب
الموجوده في اوروبا ما بين روسيا
واوكرانيا دوله قامت في خلال السنوات
اجراء استباقي حتى قبل ما يحدث الان
باستنباط اصناف قصيره العمر قصيره العمر
للقمح معناها هروب من موجات الصيف المبكر
فاصبح هذا الاجراء هو الاجراء احيانا اللي
كان له علاقه كبيره بانقاذ ملف الامن
الغذائي في مصر الحكومه تحاول طمانه
المصريين بان احتياطات القمح الموجوده
والمحصول للمحلي تكفي لتغطيه الاحتياجات
لمده كافيه اضافه الى اتخاذ مزيد من
الاجراءات للاعتماد على الانتاج المحلي
لدينا في المتوسط للمخزون الاستراتيجي ما
يتعدى ست شهور حجم الانتاج المحلي من
الاقماح حوالي من 45 الى 50% ويتم استيراد
55% تقريبا من الخارج ابتدينا ان احنا
نزيد الرقعه الزراعيه فيما يتعلق بمحصول
القمح هناك اكثر من منطقه بيتم استزراعه
فيها القمح وبالتالي بالنهايه حنصل الى
تقليل حجم الاستيراد من هذه السلعه
الاستراتيجيه تداعيات الازمه خلقت سوق
الموازيه بالنسبه الى الفلاحين وخلف
التقلبات في العقود الاجله التي يستند
اليها السوق في وقت رفعت فيه الحكومه الحد
الادنى للسعر المدفوع للمزارعين لزياده
توريد المحصول المحلي وتقول انها تخصص
ميزانيه الواردات قمح اعلى سعرا رغم
الضغوط على الموازنه العامه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا وهذه الفقره الثانيه منها
تاثيرات الحرب في اوكرانيا على الاقتصاد
المصري ومعنى الحديث عن هذا الموضوع دكتور
احمد الصفطي استاذ الاقتصاد بجامعه ريفيرا
الفرنسيه
دكتور احمد يعني تابعنا هذا تقرير الذي
تحدث بشكل اساسي عن القمح والازمه في مصر
من جراء مشكله استيراد القمح من روسيا
واوكرانيا ولكن هل هو تاثير الوحيد
الازمه حرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كان لها
اثر كبير جدا عن الاقتصاد العالمي ككل اول
حاجه عندنا كانت سلاسل الامداد والتموين
في قطاع الغذائي يعني منها مثلا زي مسلمه
اثرت على القمح اوكي في صوره اكبر من كده
قمح مش لوحده ده قمح مجموعه كبيره جدا من
المنتجات الغذائيه سواء كانت حبوب او
اسمده او او النهارده روسيا واوكرانيا من
اكبر الدول المنتجه للح الغذائيه طبعا
الحبوب الغذائيه الاقتصاديه التكلفه يعني
الدول اكثر احتياجا او اكثر فقرا هي دي
بتستورد من السوق الروسي وسوء الاوكراني
ده كمان يشمل
الاسمده الكيماويه ويشمل بعض المبيدات
الحشريه وكل هذا القطاع القطاع ده كله
تاثر تاثر كبير جدا بالحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه سواء على مستوى نقص المعروض او
مشاكل نقل الموجود بالفعل اللي كان في
المخازن بالفعل في مشاكل في نقله وتحريكه
من الاماكن المخازن بتاعته الى الاماكن
الاحتياج الخاصه به او حتى كمان على مستوى
الفتره الزمنيه التاليه يعني احنا بنقول
ايه دايما حاصرات الزراعيه لما تتاثر اي
دوله منتجه لا ياتي حاليا فقط ولكن في
الدوره الزراعيه الجايه هتشعر بالتاثير
اكثر واكثر اوكي ده احد الامور اثرت على
اسعار السلع الغذائيه في العالم كله ليه
لان الجزء تم التقصير فيه في اوكرانيا
وروسيا الدول كانت معتمد عليهم بدات تت
هذه المنتجات من دول اخرى يعني بنتكلم
بمعنى اصح على مستوى العالمي زاد الطلب
بالمقابل نقص في المعروض وده ادى لارتفاع
كبير جدا في الاسعار تتضرر الدول المختلفه
باختلاف احتياجاتها واختلاف علاقتها
بروسيا واوكرانيا نيجي على الصعيد الاخر
صعيد الطاقه سواء كانت الطاقه البتروليه
او مصادر اخرى من الطاقه زي الفحم والغاز
الطبيعي روسيا ننتقل ننتقل
في
بعد قليل ولكن
دكتور هاني هل المشكله مشكله القمح هي
المشكله الوحيده نتحدث هنا بالنسبه لمصر
بشكل خاص نتحدث بعد عام من هذه
الازمه هل استطعت مصر تجاوز تاثير هذه
الحرب وتدعيتها الاقتصاديه هو طبعا يعني
تتعات الاقتصاديه صعب ان انت تقول ان انت
عديت الاثار بتاعتها خصوصا ان ما زالت
الحرب مستمره وما زالت الازمه مستمره
وخصوصا ان
نقص سلاسل في القمح والحبوب اثر بشده على
مصر مثلا في قطاع انتاج الدواجن احنا
عندنا
العلف تقريبا كله مستورد اللي علف
الحيواني سواء للانتاج اللحوم الحمراء او
اللحوم البيضاء وده طبعا تاثر بشده نتيجه
لسلاسل
واللي اثر كمان نقص الدولار عليه بشده
فاحنا بنعاني دلوقتي من ارتفاع كبير في
الاسعار نتيجه لهذه الاجراءات وكمان
للاسف الشديد الصناعه نفسها تاثرت صناعه
بتاعه الدواجن تاثرت بشده من يعني موضوع
استيراد الاعلاف لدرجه ان احنا دلوقتي
تقريبا عندنا انتاج منخفض جدا في مزارع
كبيره كتيره قفلت والدوله بتحاول انها
تعيد بعث الحياه ولكن حتى مع الاتفاقيات
التي ابرمتها مصر مع اجانب الروسي وتلقت
كميات كبيره من القمح مؤخرا وتم الافراج
عن بعض الكميات من الحبوب هل ما زالت
الازمه مستمره بتعيد بقى بناء المنظومه من
اول وجديد قطاع الانتاج الداجيني بتبتدي
تعيد لان مش مجرد ان انت جبت العلف بقى
خلاص انت كان عندك بقى عندك نقص في
الكتاكيت الامهات والجدود تم التخلص منهم
من بعض المزارع وده سبب خسائر كبيره جدا
فانت بتعيد بناء المنظومه من اول وجديد
بتعيد بناءها تجيب امهات وجدود ثم كتاكيت
ودوره تربيه ده هياخد وقت على مسؤولي
يستقر مره ثانيه وخصوصا في مزارع كبيره
خرجت من الخدمه ده ده مثال صغير جدا عن
الاثار الجانبيه
لكن انا عايز اقول كمان ان 20% من الاسر
المصريه انخفض دخلها بشده وصل انخفاض
لاكثر من 70% نسبه
مشترياتها حتى قلت الاسر المصريه
90% من اسره المصريه بقت قللت من
استهلاكها من المواد الغذائيه وبالذات من
اللحوم وده طبعا مؤثر جدا على الصحه
العامه خصوصا ان في منظمات دوليه زي
الدبليو اتش او والفاو والاف دي اي
بيتكلموا على ان متوسط استهلاك الفرد من
البروتينات الحيوانيه لازم ما يقلش عن 33
جرام في اليوم احنا في مصر بنتكلم في 21
جرام فاحنا عندنا فجوه كبيره جدا هتاثر
كمان صحيا على الاجيال الجايه دكتور احمد
يعني بالعوده لموضوع الطاقه هناك من يقول
ان الدول النفطيه هي الوحيده التي لم
تتاثر بالازمه ما بين بالحرب في اوكرانيا
ولكن ربما تكون استفادت ولكن الدول التي
هياكلها الاقتصادي لا يعتمد على
مصادر الطاقه بشكل اساسي هل هناك دول اخرى
مشابهه لمصر الجزائر مثلا هل وضعها مماثل
لمصر طب انا هرجع على مصر في جزئيه صغيره
ان انت بتقول ايه التاثر الاخر غير التاثر
السلع الغذائيه النقد الاجنبي مصر كدوله
مصادر النقد اجنبيه بتاعتها احد اهم مصادر
النقد السياحه والسياحه المصريه احد اهم
اسواقها برضو هي روسيا واوكرانيا فبالتالي
ادى انخفاض مصادر النقد اجنبي اتنين جزء
قصاد نقد اجنبي هو المستثمر الاجنبي اللي
عنده رغبه في الاستثمار في دول مختفي
الاقتصاديات مختلفه المستثمر ده حدوث
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه او الروسيه
الاوكرانيه احدث خلل في منظومه الاستثمار
الدولي فاصبح في جزء من الهوت مان او
الانفاس السريعه بتتجه الى الاسواق
الروسيه عشان كان في ادوات مغريه للتعامل
هناك اصبح في جزء من المستثمرين بيحكم على
الاستثمار في الدول اللي بتتاثر من هذه
الحرب كل العوامل دي تفاعلت على الاقتصاد
المصري يؤدي الى احداث كبيره لعب طبعا ادت
الاحداث مختلفه على اصعده مختلفه مش بس مش
بس على مستوى الغذائيه نيجي الجزء التاني
اللي هو فيما يتعلق باسعار الطاقه
بالطبيعي بطبيعه الامور ان كل دول العالم
حصل فيها خلل يعني الاخوه في الخليج
العربي حصل ارتفاع كبير جدا في الاسعار
العربي جدا في الاسعار في الولايات
المتحده وفي اوروبا وفي كل هذه البلاد
يعني معنى هذا الكلام ان اثر الحرب لم
يقتصر على الدول الاكثر احتياجا لا تاثر
العالم كله ولكن في دول زي الدول المنتجه
للنفطاء الصادراتها من النفط تفوق
احتياجاتها من النقد الاجنبي اللي هي ذات
الفوائط دول طبعا استفادت من ارتفاع اسعار
النفط بل بالعكس ده حاولت تحافظ على سوء
النفط باسعار مرتفعه عشان كده في اجتماعات
اوبك الاخيره رفضوا زياده الانتاج ليه لان
هم عايزين السعر النفط يتوازن عند المستوى
الحالي توازنه عند المستوى الحالي للدول
المنتجه للنفط المصدره للنفط بكميات كبيره
تفوق احتياجاتها للنقد الاجنبي كاستهلاك
عندها فوائط دول اخرى زي الجزائر الجزائر
اه دوله مصدره للنفط بلا ادنى شكل لكن
الجزائر كانت بتمر بمرحله ازمات اقتصاديه
الشمال الافريقي كله اتساعه بيمر بازمه
اقتصاديه يعني انت مش بس تتكلم عن الجزائر
ليبيا كان بتاع تونس كانت الجزائر على
المغرب كل الشمال الافريقي بيمر بازمه
اقتصاديه من اوائل الربيع العربي لحد هذه
اللحظات احنا بنمر بها وبالتالي تاثره كان
اكبر تاثر الجزائر كان كبير طبعا ما فيهاش
مجال للنقاش ليبيا موقفه عندها سيء جدا
ومتازم للغايه مصر موقفه واضح والمغرب
وتونس زي ما انت شايف كل الشمال افريقيا
بيعاني حتى لو كان مصدر للنفض ما زالت
احتياجاته من نقط الاجنبي اعلى من قيمه
الارتفاع في زياده القيمه من الضعف ما زال
عنده عجوزات في الموازنه بتاعته في 30% في
بعض الاحيان في 80% في بعض الدول الاخرى
ولكن جميعها بتعاني من عجوزات في
الميزانيه العامه الخاصه بها
دكتور هاني هل نستطيع ان نقول ان تاثير
هذه الحرب كان كبير على مصر ام ان
الاقتصاد المصري في ازمه بغض النظر عن
الازمه الاوكرانيه لان كان هناك بعض
نقل وتداول الحبوب المنطقه بتاعتنا كلها
ما فيهاش بورصه صناعيه للحبوب والاقناع ده
ممكن يمثل فرصه لنا جدا السعوديه لها
تجربه عملت منطقه لوجستيه في الرياض وقدرت
انها تجبر الشركات اللي عايزه تشتغل مع
السعوديه انها تفتح مكاتب اقليميه لها
احنا ممكن نطلب من الشركات اللي بتورد لنا
الاقماح ان هي مش هناخد منكم قمح الا لو
فتحته منطقه او اشتغلت في منطقه لوجستيه
في مصر فاحنا في مثقبه مليان ان احنا ممكن
نستغل الازمه العالميه دي ويبقى لنا دور
في تداول ونقل الحبوب على مستوى العالم
خصوصا ان مصر هي رقم واحد في العالم عندك
الجزائر رقم اربعه في العالم تونس بتستورد
برضه كميات كبيره من اقناح الروسيه فانت
عندك طلب عالي جدا على القمح في منطقه
وافريقيا كمان في كمان التعاون في منظمه
عمل الجديده بين الولايات المتحده والهند
واسرائيل والامارات هدفها الاستثمار
الزراعي لتغطيه الفك الفجوه الغذائيه
الموجوده في شرق افريقيا عشان
شرق افريقيا تبقى بديل لتوريد الاقماح
والحبوب على مستوى العالم فدي برضو فرصه
كبيره جدا احنا لو قدرنا نخش معهم ونربط
او التكنولوجيا الزراعيه اللي احنا
اتعلمناها في مصر في السنوات الاخيره
بافريقيا ممكن نعمل سلاسل من الامداد
والتموين من افريقيا لمصر ونصدر للعالم
كله دكتور هاني السلاموني خبير التامنه
بالامم المتحده وشكرا جزيلا دكتور احمد
الصفطي استاذ الاقتصاد بجامعه ريفيرا
الفرنسيه اشكرك شكرا
نتابع تقرير الزميله سهام فرج حول تاثير
الازمه في اوكرانيا على السياحه في مصر
اندلاع الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه القى
بظلاله على قطاعات عديده في مصر ولكنه اثر
بشكل خاص على القطاع السياحي فمنذ غزو
روسيا لاوكرانيا في الرابعه والعشرين من
فبراير شباط عام 2022
تراجعت اعداد السياح الروس والاوكرانيين
القاصدين مصر بشكل كبير قبل الازمه كانت
اعدادهم تقدر بحوالي 40% من مجموع السياح
الذين يقصدون مصر سنويا للاستمتاع
بشواطئها غياب السياح الاوكرانيين والروس
بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا ادى الى تراجع
عائدات قطاع يساهم بما يصل الى 15% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ويجلب نقدا اجنبيا
تشتد حاجه مصر اليه
وهو صدمه في سلسله صدمات شاهدها القطاع
السياحي في مصر في السنوات الاخيره
فقد تراجعت عائده السياحه في مصر بشكل حاد
بسبب جائحه كورونا وقبلها بسبب تعليق
الرحلات الجويه المباشره بين روسيا ومطاري
شرم الشيخ والغردقه لست سنوات بعد حادثه
تحطم طائره ركاب تقل سياحا روسيا
بعدها شهد القطاع منتعاشه قصيره الامد
عندما استانفت الرحلات المباشره بين روسيا
والمدينتين الواقعتين على سواحل البحر
الاحمر في اغسطس اب عام 2021
لكنه سرعان ما انتكس مجددا بسبب الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وفي ظل تراجع اعداد الوافدين اليها من
اوكرانيا وروسيا تتجه مصر نحو اسواق اخرى
لجذب المزيد من السياح من دول غرب اوروبا
ومنطقه الخليج وكذلك الصين من خلال تكثيف
حملاتها الدعائيه والترويجيه تدفق السياح
الصينيين الى مصر كان قد توقف بالكامل
بسبب جائحه كورونا لمده ثلاث سنوات قبل ان
يستانف في يناير الماضي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا وهذه الفقره الاخيره من
هوا مصر والتي يتناول فيها تاثير الحرب في
اوكرانيا على قطاع السياحه في مصر شرف ان
يكون معنا استاذ باسم حلقه نقيب اسيحيين
اهلا بحضرتك معنا اهلا وسهلا ويشرفنا كذلك
استاذ رامي فايز عضو غرفه المنشات
الفندقيه البحر الاحمر اهلا بكم
استاذ باسم تاثير الحرب في اوكرانيا على
السياحه في مصر هل هو يقتصر فقط على
المدن الواقعه على البحر الاحمر ام انه
تاثير على المستوى العام للسياح في مصر
خلينا نقول انه تاثير هذه الحرب اثر بشكل
مباشر على اعداد السياحين اللي بيجوا من
روسيا واوكرانيا الى مصر ودول كانوا
بيشكلوا حوالي 40% من نسبه عدد السواح
اللي كانوا بيوصلوا مصري يمكن النسبه
الاكبر كانت في مدينه شرم الشيخ والغردقه
ومرسى علم لكن كان بياخد منها رحلات
الاوفردي الى مدينه الاقصر واسوان
والقاهره لمشاهده الاثار في الجيزه
طبعا هذه الحرب اثرت بشكل كبير جدا على
اقتصاديات مصر من السياحه المصريه
وبالتالي اصبح هناك في مشكله في الدخل وفي
تشغيل عمليه الفنادق وده اللي خلانا في
القطاع السياحي نبدا نتحرك في فتح اسواق
بديله وجديده عشان نقدر ان احنا نعظم من
الدخل من هذا القطاع ونعوض خسائر اعداد
السائحين اللي بتيجي لانه خلي بال حضرتك
انه
التاثير ليس فقط من روسيا واوكرانيا ولكن
يعني التاثير كان على مستوى العالم كله في
المستوى الاقتصادي لان احنا عارفين انه
السياحه في العالم بتبدا من فائض من
الاقتصاد وبالتالي يقدر ان هو يسافر منه
وهذه الحرب اثرت على العالم كله وبالتالي
التاثير على القطاع السياحي كان تاثير
مباشر على مصر استاذ رامي هل التاثير
بالنسبه
للشرم الشيخ غردقه المدن الواقعه على ساحل
البحر الاحمر كان
غياب فقط السياح من روسيا واوكرانيا حتى
وان كان عددهم كبير ام ان كان هناك غيابات
اخرى من الدول الاوروبيه بشكل عام هو في
اول طبعا بدايه العمليات العسكريه ما بين
روسيا وما بين اوكرانيا طبعا احنا بعد
فقداننا لسوء الاوكراني بالكامل لو قد
يكون كان ساعتها بعد بعد خلصنا موضوع
الكوفيد على تاثيره على مصر الى حد كبير
احنا فقدنا حوالي 30% من حجم سياحه كانت
بالجنه من بعد عشرين واحد وعشرين من
السياحه الاوكرانيه ببدايه الحرب الروسيه
ولكن طبعا بدايه الدنيا ابتدت تتبلور
قدامنا اكتر طبعا الروس كمان بطلوا يجوا
لان كان ساعتها ابتدى يحصل بان الحظر
الجوي على روسيا ابتدا يحصل كمان المسارات
الجويه اللي بتسلقها الطيران اللي بيطلع
من مطار شرمتي او معظم مطارات محافظات
الروسيه لمنطقه زي شرم الشيخ او مرسى علم
او الغردقه ابتدت هي كمان تاخد مسارات
اطول لما بتاخد مسارات اطول في الكورس
الطيران ابتدى السعر
الاقامه والسفر على الجانب الروسي كمان
يبتدي يزيد طبعا مع انخفاض سعر الروبل
قصاد الدولار ابتدا الريح لنفسها تبقى
زياده قوي على المواطن الروسي فابت بدل ما
هي تبقى يا فندم حوالي 30 رحله طيران في
اليوم للمطارات المصريه قد يكون تتقلصت من
اتنين لاربعه رحلات في الاسبوع الوقت
الحالي طبعا ابتدت ساعتها كانت السوق مثلا
اللي تشيكي البولندي الالماني كانوا لسه
بيتحسسوا الطريق خلال الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه لما ابتدت الدنيا يعني تبتدي تتحط
معايير للحرب شويه ابتدينا يسترجع لنا
تاني السوق البولندي بكثره جدا سوق
التشيكي ابتدى يشتغل معانا كويس جدا في
مصر ابتدا السوق الالماني هو اكتر سوق
بيجيب دلوقتي حاليا السياحه باعداد كبيره
لمصر فاحنا الى حد ما كنا فقدنا فقط لا
غير
تلت عدد السياحه الروسيه والاوكرانيه اللي
وافدها لمصر ولكن كان لفتره محدوده فقط
انما لغايه دلوقتي الحمد لله المعادلات
ترجع تاني طبعتها استاذ باسم هل قطاع
السياحه في مصر يعاني منذ سنوات هل هذا
التاثير كان كبير
بسبب غياب السياح من اوكرانيا وقلهم من
روسيا بشكل اساسي هل فاقد من ازمه هذا
القطاع ام انه بقي في نفس معدلته خلينا
نتفق انه الاحداث يعني اللي مرت بالعالم
خلال السنوات الماضيه اثرت بشكل كبير جدا
على السياحه في مصر ولكن في مصر احنا
عندنا في القطاع السياحي عدد كبير من
الخبراء اللي دايما بيحاولوا يختلقوا فرص
جديده للسياحه بنشتغل على محورين محور خاص
بالتسويق والمشاركه في المعارض السياحيه
الدوليه لفتح اسواق جديده مع منظمه رحلات
في مختلف دول العالم وفي نفس الوقت المحور
الداخلي الخاص بالدوله في عمليه تطوير
المتاحف المصريه وتطوير الاماكن السياحيه
واحنا شفنا متحف الحضاره المصري تم خلال
هذه الازمه ونقل المومياوات لها شفنا في
طريق الكباش في الاقصر شفنا الانتهاء من
مطار سفنكس الدولي اللي بدا فعلا في
التشغيلاته وبالتالي احنا بدانا نهتم
بالبنيه التحتيه جنبا الى جنب خلال هذه
الازمه مع التسويق في الخارج عشان نقدر
نعظم من الدخل السياحي ويمكن في تصريح مهم
جدا لدوله رئيس الوزراء المصري باستهداف
30 مليون سائح خلال الثلاث سنوات القادمه
وبالتالي القطاع السياحي في مصر بدا يعمل
على هذا
الموضوع وطبعا احنا عندنا عدد كبير جدا من
المنشات الفندقيه تحت
التاسيس او الانشاء وبالتالي هناك توجيهات
من الحكومه المصريه بسرعه الانتهاء من هذه
المنشات الفندقيه لزياده عدد الغرف
الفندقيه عشان نقدر نستوعب اعداد اكتر
طبعا مع افتتاح مطار سفنكس الدولي اصبحت
هناك فرصه اكبر لزياده عدد السواح في
وخصوصا في المناطق الخاصه به زي العاصمه
في القاهره والجيزه لانه نقدر من خلاله
ناخذ الاوفر داي من منطقه المدن اللي هي
مقدس يعني مليانه بالسواح وخصوصا في البحر
الاحمر وسينا نقدر ان احنا نستضيفهم في
القاهره ونعمل عمليه التشغيل ولو حضرتك
تابعت النهارده
حاله الاشغالات اللي موجوده في مدينه
الاقصر واسوان هتلاقيها يعني تخطط اللي
يمكن 90% او 95% استاذ رامي يعني هل تاثرت
المنشات الفندقيه في المحافظات الواقعه
على الساحل او المدن الواقعه على الساحل
البحر الاحمر بسبب قله السياح في الفتره
الاخيره حتى وان بدا يتم تدارك هذا الوضع
في اول الفتره يا فندم اه طبعا حصل تاثر
وكانت كبير جدا جدا انما الحمد لله احنا
تدركنا زي ما كان الاستاذ باسم قال تدركنا
ببعض الاسواق اللي كانت مساعده لينا قوي
سوق التشيكي البولندي الالماني هل هل يقوم
بتغطيه هذه الفجوه الكبيره من السياح من
اوكرانيا يعني رئيس هيئه تنشيط السياحي
يقول انه فقدنا السياحه الاوكرانيه
بالكامل و60% تقريبا من الساحه الروسيه
الى حد كبير احنا يعني عملنا
نستوعب العدد اللي احنا فقدناه احنا طبعا
مش هنقدر نعوض نفس الارقام اللي احنا
فقدناها من الروسي من الاوكرانيين دول
اسواق ثقيله جدا بالنسبه لسوق المصري
ويعملوا معضله كبيره جدا في الدخل خزينه
الدوله المصريه في حاله فقدانهم بالكامل
انما احنا السوق الروسي لغايه دلوقتي
الاربع طيارات اللي بيجوا لنا في الاسبوع
يعني حوالي متوسط حوالي يعني 20 طياره
مثلا في الشهر او 16 طياره في الشهر دول
الى حد كبير بيبتدوا يساعدوا شويه خلي
بالك ان كمان دلوقتي احنا التارجت اللي
احنا محطوط للدوله المصريه مليون سائح 30
مليار دولار في خلال اربع سنين جايين ده
الهدف الاستراتيجي حاليا للحكومه المصريه
والدوله المصريه احنا بافتاح مطار زي مطار
اسفنجس عندك القطار السريع اللي هيبتدي
يشتغل ما بين محافظات البحر الاحمر
ومحافظات الداخليه زي الاقصر ان شاء الله
بدايه من اخر 20 اول 20 25 هيبتدي يعمل
مزيج ما بين السياحه الشاطئيه والسياحه
الثقافيه مصر كانت مفتقده النوع ده من
انواع السياحه السريعه ان انت تبتدي تاخد
مثلا فطارك في البحر الاحمر تتغدى في
الاقصر وتشوف كل المعابد اللي انت بتشوفها
في الداخل المصري وبعدين بترجع تاني بتعمل
اوفر نايت في منطقه البحر الاحمر عندك زي
مطار اسفنجس بيبتدي يخدم النهارده بطريقه
جديده جدا على
المتحف المصري الجديد ان شاء الله يتفتح
في الكوارتر الثاني ان شاء الله من 20 ل
23 اللي هو المفروض هيدرب يبقى اكبر متحف
على مستوى العالم كله يا فندم 100,000
قطعه اثريه موجوده قدامك بتشوفها بطريقه
عرض يعني هناك بحث البدائل جديده لتعويض
الفقد في السياحه سواء في المدن الواقعه
لصاحب البحر الاحمر او بقيه المدن المصريه
بكل تاكيد لان انت النهارده انا انا مفتقد
هنا في مصر
ان النهارده انا نجاحي في السياحه المصريه
يا فندم ان انا ابتدي اجيب نفس جيست اللي
بيجي مره واتنين وتلاته اجيبه المره
الرابعه بطريقه جديده بطريقه عرض متحفيه
جديده بطرق جديده باسرع ان هو يوصل
للبوينت من البوينت ايه لبوينت به بطريقه
اسرع بطريقه اريح لازم السائح يبتدي ينزل
يبتدي يحس ان في تغير في الداخل المصري
وده ان شاء الله
هناك من قال انه من الطرق الترويج للسياحه
ما يعرف بالسياحه التعليميه انه تم وضع
شروط ميسره للطلاب الاجانب
للدراسه في مصر وزياده عدد الوافدين حتى
من 5% ل 25% هل هذا قد يؤثر ايجابيا على
قطاع السياحه بشكل عام اه طبعا لانه احنا
عارفين انه السياحه التعليميه سياحه تعتبر
طويله المده في الاقامه وفي الانفاق ومصر
يمكن عده تصاريح كتيره جدا لعدد كبير من
الجامعات الدوليه وهناك اتفاقيات
وبروتوكولات مشتركه ما بين جامعات مصريه
وجامعات الدوليه عالميه ذات نقول يعني
التصنيف عالي وبالتالي ده بيدفع ويشجع عدد
كبير من العرب خصوصا وعدد من الافارقه
للوصول الى مصر وقضاء عمليه التعليم فيها
والحصول على شهادات لمده طويله عايزين
نقول انه في السياحه في هذا المجال بيتطلب
الى اقامات اطول في الفنادق او ايجار شقق
فندقيه معينه خلال فتره الدراسه مصاريف
بتدفع في الخزانه المصريه من العملات
الاجنبيه وتعزز الاحتياط النقدي في البنك
المركزي كل هذا
يعني القطاع التعليمي بيساعد بشكل كبير
جدا وبيعوض الجاب اللي فقدته مصر من
السياحات القصيره اللي هي
ترجع تاني بفوليوم كبير جدا وابتدى يرجع
تاني على الفنادق المصريه ايا كان موقعها
ايه في جوه جوه مروريه المصريه سواء في
الغردقه شرم مرسى علم الاقصر اسوان طابا
دهب نويبع المناطق كلها ابتدت الناس
المدربه اللي لها تعامل مباشره وغير مباشر
ابتدت ترجع تاني بصفه مباشره الحمد لله
القطاع السياحي المصري بيتعافى قد يكون
القطاع السياحي دائما يعني اول حاجه
بتتاثر من اي مشكله واخر حاجه بتتعافى من
اساس المشكله
بالبحر الاحمر اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
في حلقه نقيب السياحيين اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
شكرا
انتهت هذه الحلقه